maybe also just a comment on AGI
representing before even the term
existed representing a kind of community
like you've talked about this in the
past sort of a is coming in waves but
there's always been this community of
people who dream about creating general
human levels super intelligent systems
can you maybe give your sense of the
history of this community as it exists
today is it existed before this deep
learning revolution all throughout the
winters and the summers of AI sure first
I would say as a side point the winters
and summers of AI are greatly
exaggerated by by Americans and in the
if you look at the publication record of
the artificial intelligence community
since said the 1950s you would find a
pretty steady growth in advance of ideas
and papers and what's thought of as an
AI winter a summer was sort of how much
money is the US military pumping India
which was was meaningful on the other
hand there was a I going on in Germany
UK and in Japan and in Russia all over
the place while US military got more in
less less enthused about AI so what I
mean that happened to be just for people
who don't know the US military happened
to be the main source of funding for AI
research so another way to phrase that
is it's up and down of funding for
artificial intelligence research and I
would say the correlation between
funding and intellectual advance was not
a hundred percent right because I mean
in in Russia as an example or in Germany
there was less dollar funding than in
the US but many foundational ideas were
were laid out but it was more theory
that than implementation right and us
really excelled at sort of breaking
through from theoretical papers to
working implementations which which did
go up and down somewhat with the US
military funding but still I mean you
can look in the 1980s Dietrich Turner in
Germany I
self-driving cars on the Autobahn right
and I'm in this it was a little early
with regard to the car industry so it
didn't catch on such as has has happened
now but I mean that whole advancement of
self-driving car technology in Germany
was pretty much independent of AI
military summers and winters in the US
so that there's been more going on in AI
globally then not only most people on
the planet realized but then most new AI
phd's realized because they've come up
with in a certain sub sub field of AI
and haven't had to look so much so much
beyond that but I would say when I got
when I got my PhD in 1989 in mathematics
I was interested in AI already in
Philadelphia yeah I started at NYU then
I transferred to Philadelphia to Temple
University good old North Philly nice
feeling yeah yeah yeah the pearl of
pearl of the u.s. you never stopped at a
red light then because you referred if
you stopped at a red light so more car
Jackie see I strive through every red
light yeah every everyday driving or
bicycling to Temple from my house was it
like a new new adventure but yeah when I
the reason I didn't do a PhD in AI was
what people were doing in the academic
AI field then was just astoundingly
boring and seemed wrongheaded to me it
was really like rule-based expert
systems and production systems and
actually I loved mathematical logic I
had nothing against logic as the
cognitive engine for an AI but the idea
that you could type in the knowledge
that a I would need to think seemed just
completely stupid and and then and
wrongheaded to me I mean you can use
logic if you want but somehow the system
has got to be automated learning right
it should be learning from experience
and the AI feel then was not interested
in learning from experience I mean some
researchers certainly were I mean I
remember in mid 80s I discovered a book
by John undress which was it was about
reinforcement learning system called
purpose pu RR - PU SS which was an
acronym that I can't even remember what
it was for but purpose anyway but he I
mean that was a system that was supposed
to be an AGI and basically by some sort
of fancy like Markov decision process
learning it was supposed to learn
everything just from the bits coming
into it and learned to maximize its
reward and become become intelligent
right so that was there in academia back
then but it was like isolated scattered
weird people but all these isolated
scattered weird people in that period I
mean they they laid the intellectual
grounds for what happened later so you
look at John Andreas at University of
Canterbury with his purpose
reinforcement learning Markov system he
was the PhD supervisor for John Cleary
in New Zealand now John Cleary worked
with me when I was at Waikato University
in 1993 in New Zealand and he worked
with Ian Witten there and they launched
Weka which was the first open source
machine learning toolkit which was
launched in I guess 93 or 94 when I was
at Waikato University written in Java
unfortunate written in Java which was a
cool language back then I guess it's
told well it's not cool anymore but I
find like most programmers now I find
Java unnecessarily bloated but back then
it was like Java or C++ basically in
Java was oriented so it was easier for
students amusingly a lot of the work on
Weka when we were in New Zealand was
funded by a u.s. sorry a New Zealand
government grant tease machine learning
to predict the menstrual cycles of cows
so in the u.s. all the grant funding for
AI was about how to how to kill people
or spy on people it's all about cows or
kiwifruits
yeah so yeah anyway I mean I'm John
Andreas had his probability theory based
reinforcement learning proto AGI John
Cleary was trying to do much more
ambitious probabilistic AGI systems now
John Cleary helped do Weka which
the first open source machine learning
tool gets to the predecessor for
tensorflow and torture and all these
things also Shayne leg what was at
Wakanda working with working with with
with John clearin in Ian Witten and this
whole group and and then working with my
own companies my company web Mangia
company I had in the late 90s with a
team there at ykv University which is
how Shane got his head full of of a GI
which led him to go on and with demo
sasame's found deep mind so what you can
see through that lineage is you know in
the 80s and 70s john andreas was trying
to build probabilistic reinforcement
lineage eos systems the technology the
computers just weren't there to support
his ideas were very similar to what
people are doing now but you know
although he's long since passed away and
didn't become that famous outside of
Canterbury I mean the lineage of ideas
passed on from him to his students to
their students you can go trace directly
from there to me and to end to deep mind
right so that there was a lot going on
in AGI that did ultimately lay the
groundwork what we have today but there
wasn't there wasn't a community right
and so what when I when I started trying
to pull together in AGI community it was
in the I guess the early aughts when I
was living in in Washington DC and
making a living doing
they are consulting for various various
US government agencies and I organized
the first
Agia workshop in 2006 and I mean it
wasn't it wasn't like it was literally
in my basement or something I mean it
was it was in the conference room I
didn't Marriott in Bethesda it's not
that not that edgy or underground
unfortunately but still people attended
that's 60 or something that's something
I mean DC has a lot of a arguing on
probably until the last five or 10 years
much more than Silicon Valley although
it's just quiet because of the nature of
what will happen what happens in in DC
their business isn't different by PR
mostly when something starts to work
really well it's taken black and becomes
even even more
but yeah the thing is that really had
the feeling of a group of starry-eyed
Mavericks like yeah huddled in a
basement like plotting how to overthrow
the the narrow AI establishment and you
know for the first time in some cases
coming together with others who shared
their passion for AGI and the technical
seriousness about about working on it
right and that I mean that's very very
different than what we have today I mean
now now it's a little bit different we
have a GI conference every year and
there's several hundred people rather
than than 50 not now it's more like this
is the main gathering of people who want
to achieve AGI and think that
large-scale nonlinear regression is is
not the Golden Path to AGI yeah so I
mean again you're on our yeah yeah yeah
well certain architectures for sure for
learning using neural networks oh yeah
the AGI conferences are sort of now the
main concentration of people not
obsessed with deep neuron that Rob deep
reinforcement learning but but still
interested in in in a in a GI not not
not not the only ones I mean that
there's other little conferences and
groupings interested in the human level
AI and and cognitive art cognitive
architectures and so forth yeah it's
it's been a big shift like that back
then you couldn't really it will be very
very edgy then to give a University
Department seminar that mentioned a GI
or human level yeah it was more like you
had to talk about something more
short-term and immediately practical
then you know in the bar after the
seminar you convulsion about a GI in the
same breath as time travel or the
simulation hypothesis or something right
whereas now now a GI is not only in the
academic seminar room like you have
Vladimir Putin those with AGI is and
he's like Russia needs to become the
leader in AGI right so national leaders
and CEOs of large corporations I mean
CTO of Intel Justin Ratner this was
years ago a singularity summit
conference 2008 or something he's like
we believe very Kurzweil the singularity
will happen in 2045 and it will have
Intel Inside I mean so it's gone it's
gone from being something which is the
pursuit of like crazed Mavericks
crackpots and science fiction fanatics
to being you know a marketing term for
large large corporations and the
national leaders which is a astounding
transition but yeah in the in the course
of this transition I think a bunch of
sub communities have formed and the
community around the AGI conference
series is certainly one of them it
hasn't grown as big as I might have
liked it to on the other hand you know
sometimes a modest-sized community can
be better for making intellectual
progress also like you get it with
society for neuroscience conference you
have 35 or 40 thousand neuroscientists
on the one hand it's amazing on the
other hand you're not going to talk to
the leaders of the of the field there if
you're an outsider and since in the same
sense the triple AI the artificial
intelligence the main kind of generic
artificial intelligence community
conference it's too big it's too
amorphous like it doesn't makes yeah it
doesn't and knit knits has become a
company advertising yet so I mean to
comment on the role of AGI in the
research community I'd still if you look
at Europe's if you look at cvpr if you
look at these I clear
you know AGI is still seen as the
outcast that was still I would say in
these main machine learning in these
main artificial intelligence conferences
amongst the researchers I don't know if
it's an accepted term yet I what I've
seen bravely you mention shame leg is
deep mind and then open AI are the two
places that are I would say
unapologetically so far
I think it's actually changing
unfortunately but so far they've been
pushing the idea that the goal is to
create an AGI well they have billions of
dollars behind them so I'm in that
they're in the public mind that that
certainly carries some umph right I mean
I mean they all don't researchers right
they know there are great teams I'm in
deep mind in particular yeah and they
have I mean deep - Marcus hotter walking
around I mean there there's all these
folks who basically their full-time
position involves I mean dreaming about
creating a GI I mean Google brain has a
lot of amazing
EDI oriented people awesome and then and
I mean so I'd say from a public
marketing view deep mind and open AI are
the two large well-funded organizations
that have put the term and concept AGI
out there sort of as part of their
public image but I mean they're
certainly not that there are other
groups that are doing research that
seems just as as as a GIS to me I mean
including a bunch of groups in Google's
main main Mount View office
so yeah it's true AGI is somewhat away
from the mainstream now but if you
compare to where it was mine you know 15
years ago there's an there's there's
there's been an amazing mainstreaming
you could say the same thing about super
longevity research which is one of my my
application areas I'm excited about I
mean I've been talking about this since
the 90s but working on this since 2001
and back then really to say you're
trying to create therapies to allow
people to live hundreds or thousands of
years you you were way way way way out
of out of the industry academic
mainstream but now you know Google had
had Project calico craig Venter at human
longevity incorporated and once once the
suits come marching in right once once
there's big money in it then people are
forced to take it take it seriously
because that's the way mark modern
society works so it's still not as
mainstream as cancer research
just as AGI is not as mainstream as
automated driving or something but the
degree of mainstreaming that's happened
in the last you know 10 to 15 years is
is astounding to those of us who've been
at it for a while
you